[Musique]
nous voilà arrivés au terme de ce nouvel
exercice budgétaire et je veux ici
saluer le travail mené par tous les
parlementaires qui ont cherché à
enrichir ce texte dans un état d'esprit
constructif mais comme l'année dernière
les oppositions restent sur leur
position de principe ne pas budget quel
qu'en soit le
contenu bonjour et bienvenue dans les
grands débats comme tous les ans le
budget a été adopté juste avant la trêve
des confiseurs mais pour la 2è année
consécutive la première ministre a eu
recours au
493 pour donner des moyens inédits à
notre
sécurité notre justice et nos armées
pour permettre des investissements sans
précédent dans la transition
écologiqueer
s pour accrore la DGF des communes pour
respecter notre engagement de ne pas
augmenter les impôts ou encore pour nous
inscrire dans une trajectoire de
réduction de nos déficits
publics sur le fondement de l'article 49
aléa 3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
l'ensemble du projet doit de finan pour
2024 je vous remercie je vousci madame
la Première ministre
nous sommes le 17 octobre c'est le coup
d'envoi de la discussion budgétaire dans
l'hémicycle la semaine précédente le
volet recette du projet de loi de
finance a été rejeté en commission les
oppositions ont fait bloc contre le
gouvernement alors le discours du
ministre de l'économie est tout de suite
très
politique madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les député monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
cher Thomas je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette discussion générale
du projet de loi de finances pour
2024 je voudrais commencer cette
intervention en remerciant les députés
de notre
majorité vous avez fait
preuve d'une grande
constance dans notre politique
économique la politique de menons depuis
près de 7 ans avec le président de la
République donne des résultats parmi les
meilleurs de toutes les grandes
économies de la zone euro par conséquent
nous maintiendrons dans les années qui
viennent cette politique de l'OF cette
politique va nous permettre d'atteindre
une croissance de 1 % en 2023 chiffre
conforme aux prévisions du gouvernement
chiffre conforme à l'évaluation que
j'avais faite à cette tribune il y a 1
an malgré le scepticisme de nombreux
économistes comme quoi la représentation
nationale peut voir plus juste que les
économistes la réalisation notre
objectif de croissance en 2023 nous
permet par conséquent d'être confiant
pour la réalisation de notre objectif de
croissance pour 2024 1,4 % très proche
de ce cas précisé le Fond Monétaire
International il y a quelques jours nous
maintiendrons cette politique de l'offre
parce qu'elle nous a permis de mettre
fin à l'hémorragie de délocalisation de
fermeture d'usine que nous avons connu
au cours des qu décennies précédentes
nous la maintiendrons parce qu'elle a
permis de recréer des filières notamment
dans le domaine des batteries
électriques avec l'ouverture de 4 g
Factory dans les années qui viennent
nous la maintiendrons parce qu'elle nous
a permis de créer 2 millions d'emplois
au cours des 7 années passées 100000
emplois industriels et de rouvrir 300
usines sur le sol français vous avez
fait de la France le pays le plus
attractif en Europe vous avez fait
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
majorité de la France un pays qui réussi
économiquement vous avez tourné la
France vers l'avenir avec une ambition
devenir la première nation décarboné en
Europe à horizon 2040 je veux vous
remercier de votre constance je veux
vous remercier de votre cohérence vous
pouvez être fier des résultats
économiques de la nation
française
alors j'entends parfois les doutes les
inquiétudes de certains qui nous disent
mais vous avez pris des décisions qui
pourraient vous amener à revenir sur
cette politique je rappelle que dans le
budget 2024 nous allons engager une
baisse d'impôt de production d'un
milliard d'euros qui nous amènera à
supprimer définitivement la CVAE dans
les meilleurs délais et avoir des impôts
de production plus compétitifs par
rapport à nos grands partenaires
industriels dans le contexte budgétaire
contraint que nous connaissons je
vousoud voudrait que chacun mesure
l'effort qui est fait en faveur des PME
et du monde industriel en engageant
comme seule baisse d'impôt majeur en
2024 une baisse des impôts de production
pour les entreprises on ne peut pas
exprimer plus clairement notre
détermination à tenir le fil de notre
politique
économique je voudrais aussi remercier
la majorité pour sa solidité dans les
débat budgétaire vous avez tenu depuis
plusieurs jours et en particulier le
rapporteur général du budget qui a fait
preuve d'une constance d'une fermeté et
d'une disponibilité totale depuis
plusieurs
semaines avec le wiip Mathieu lefève que
je remercie également et avec l'ensemble
des commissaires de la commission des
finances vous aveit tenu une ligne de
responsabilité budgétaire dans un temps
où il est plus facile de proposer des
augmentations de dépenses que des
économies des amendements dépensiers il
en a plus comme à Gravelotte sur les
3000 amendements déposés en commission
des finances 10 % augmente la fiscalité
80 % augmente la dépense publique crédit
d'impôt sur la TVA crédit d'impôt pour
le paiement d'un autre impôt TICPE
flottante baisse de la TVA baisse de la
CSG crédit d'impôt pour les animaux
domestiques j'en passe et des meilleurs
aucune économie que des dépenses publ
vous êtes les seuls mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la majorité à
avoir fait preuve de responsabilité
budgétaire alors j'entends que du côté
des
républicains j'entends que du côté des
républicains vous nous demandez de
réduire davantage la dépense publique
sage résolution mais alors pourquoi et
j'aimerais que vous répondiez à cette
question sur 1546 amendements que vous
avez déposé seul qu amendements
réduisent la dépense publique les autres
engageant 100 milliards d'euros de
dépense publique supplémentaire
décidément il y a loin de la coupe aux
lèvres et je passe et je passe sur le
déluge fiscal de la France insoumise
pour lesquels un bon impôt est un impôt
à 100 % ou sur les inventions baroque du
rassemblement national qui supprime
l'impôt avant 30 ans et le travail après
60 dans le fond les oppositions
imaginent un monde où tout est gratuit
le malheur et la réalité c'est que tout
coûte quelque chose que tout a un coût
et que l'air de l'argent gratuit est
définitivement fini et qu'il serait
temps que les oppositions s'en rendent
enfin compte tout coûte et je dirais
même que tout coûte de plus en plus cher
puisque les taux d'intérêt ont augmenté
et que la charge de la dette
représentera 74 milliards d'euros en
2027 le désendettement de la nation et
donc un impératif absolu et je suis fier
de pouvoir compter sur le sens des
responsabilités de la majorité pour
tenir la ligne du désendettement
accéléré de la
France je le dis avec d'autant plus de
conviction que nous pouvons faire face
chacun le mesure à un troisième choc
économique après le choc du covid et le
choc inflationniste avec le risque
d'extension du conflit au Proche Orient
il faut vraiment faire preuve
d'irresponsabilité pour ne pas voir que
les événements actuels nous commandent
de reconstituer nos marges de manœuvre
re pour être capable de protéger nos
compatriotes en cas de nécessité notre
pays tiendra donc son engagement de
ramener le déficit public à 4,4 % en
2024 comme il aura tenu son engagement
de déficit public à 4,9 % en
2023 nos actes sont en cohérence avec
nos engagements notre objectif je le
réaffirme est de revenir sous 3 %
déficit public en 2027 d'accélérer le
désendettement de la France et et de
rétablir les équilibres financiers de
notre pays nous engageons pour cela 16
milliards d'euros d'économie dans ce
budget 2024 qui eux sont sérieusement
documentés avec la sortie du bouclier
énergétique la fin de certaines aides
aux entreprises la fin du dispostif
Pinel pour le logement et le recentrage
de la politique de l'emploi je vois que
1 milliard d'euros d'économie
supplémentair ont été identifiés par le
rapporteur général du budget et par les
commissaires des finances de la majorité
je tiens à leur dire à cette tribune que
je soutiens leur proposition d'un
milliard d'euros d'économie
supplémentaire mon troisème message est
un message de fierté votre majorité
notre majorité peut et doit être fier de
son budget d'abord c'est un budget qui
protège et il apporte la preuve tangible
qu'on peut très bien rétablir les
comptes publics sans passer
nécessairement par la cas
austérité je vais vous donner quatre
exemples premier exemple nous indexons
dans ce budget pour 2024 l'intégralité
des prestations sociales le barè de
l'impôt sur le revenu sur l'inflation
quant aux pensions de retraite elles
seront également revalorisé de 5,2 %
pour protéger nos aînés des effets de
l'inflation et de l'augmentation des
prix cette protection contre l'inflation
représente un coût total de 25 milliards
d'euros pour la dépense public c'est la
meilleure illustration que tout en ayant
un budget ambitieux et responsable nous
protégeons les plus fragiles les plus
modestes et les plus exposés aux
conséquences de l'inflation deuxième
exemple nous maintenons et nous sommes
le seul pays européen à le faire une
aide pour payer la facture d'électricité
je connais l'inquiétude de nos
compatriotes face à l'augmentation de
leur facture d'électricité je rappelle
que l'État paye aujourd'hui 34 % des
factures d'électricité des ménages et
que ce soutien se poursuit VI en 2024 et
nous coûtera 10 milliards d'euros aucun
pays européen ne fait la même chose pour
protéger ses compatriotes contre
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
trème exemple nous allons soutenir les
ménages qui ont le plus de mal à accéder
à un crédit pour se loger chacun voit
bien qu'avec l'explosion des taux
d'intérêt l'offre de crédit baisse
drastiquement qu'elle a diminué de près
de moitié par mois 10 milliards d'euros
de crédit immobilier produit contre 20
milliards d'euros avant l' ation des
taux il est donc nécessaire de réagir
pour éviter une crise immobilière et
permettre au plus grand nombre possible
de ménages d'avoir accès à crédit
immobilier nous changeons donc les
règles du prê à tau zéro pour permettre
à un plus grand nombre de personnes
d'avoir accès à ces prêts dans des
conditions plus favorables et nous
continuerons à travailler sur le prêt à
taux bonifié enfin 4e et dernier exemple
de la protection qui est assurée par ce
budget 2024 tout en gardant l'esprit de
de responsabilité qui nous est cher un
exemple que je cite même si les pontants
sont plus modestes parce qu'il est cher
au cœur du président Mayard et un
certain nombre de députés ici nous
réduirons les efforts financiers
demandés au CCI et au CMA à hauteur
respectivement de 25 millions d'euros et
de 13 millions d'euros pour leur
permettre de continuer leur travail dans
les meilleures conditions
possibles ce
budget est aussi un budget qui prépare
l'avenir je rappelle que nous engageons
dans le PLF 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la transition
écologique ce qui porte le total de nos
engagements financiers pour la
transition écologique à 41 milliards
d'euros nous augmentons ma prime renve
nous augmentons le bonus sur les
véhicules électriques nous recentrons le
bonus sur les véhicules électriques
exclusivement sur les véhicules les
moins lourds et sur les véhicules les
moins polluants je veux dire les choses
clairement les contribuables français
n'ont pas à financer les véhicules qui
n'ont de verre que le nom nous mettons
aussi en place pour la première fois en
Europe un crédit d'impôt vert pour
encourager le développement de nouvelles
filières industrielles et répondre à
l'inflation reduction Act
américain cette décision elle vient
après de multiples changements
structurels que nous avons porter avec
le président de la République à
l'échelle européenne pour défendre notre
industrie défendre nos filières
industrielles la dette en commun le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières le renforcement des contrôles
sur les investissements étrangers les
investissements dans les programmes d'
collectif européens les aides d'État
pour les grands projets industriels tout
cela dessine et construit concrètement
une Europe souveraine qui apprend enfin
à défendre ses intérêts économiques son
savoir-faire technologique ses usines
ses ouvriers et son patrimoine
industriel tout cela précède d'ailleurs
d'autres combats idéologiques à venir au
niveau européen notamment le combat pour
le contenu européen je ne vois pas
pourquoi en Chine comme aux États-Unis
on réserve les aides publiques à des
bien industriels qui ont un contenu
chinois ou un contenu américain et que
nous-même nous ne réserverions pas nos
aides publiques à des biens industriels
qui ont un contenu industriel français
allemand italien espagnol ou belge un
contenu
européen nous avons passé un accord avec
le monde agricole nous avons passé un
accord avec les entreprises et travaux
publics pour faire évoluer la fiscalité
sur le GNR je m'engage ici à ce que
toutes les recettes fiscales
supplémentaires soit consacré à
l'accompagnement des exploitations
agricoles à l'accompagnement des PME des
travaux publics et à la consolidation de
la filière des
biocarburants c'est aussi un budget qui
garantit un État
fort capable d'assurer dans les
meilleures conditions ses missions
régaliennes quand la nation est menacée
quand la nation est attaquée par le
terrorisme il serait irresponsable de ne
pas nous donner les moyens de protéger
la nation française de soutenir nos
forces de l'ordre de soutenir nos
policiers nos gendarmes exposés au
premier chef par cette menace nous
augmenterons donc le budget du ministère
des armées nous augmenterons le budget
du ministère de l'Intérieur et nous
augmentons le budget du ministère de la
justice par ailleurs quand la nation
fait face à des révolutions
technologique majeur comme celle de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
définir les nouveaux rapports de
puissance entre les nation il est tout
aussi essentiel d'investir dans
l'éducation et dans la formation nous
continuerons à soutenir le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et ses enseignants
comme l'ensemble de ces personnels
l'éducation est en réalité le premier
défi économique de la nation française
et permettez-moi à cette occasion de
redire aux enseignants toute mon
admiration et leur exprimer ma gratitude
pour leur travail en auprès de nos
enfants nous sommes à leur côté dans les
heures difficiles et douloureuses que
les enseignants
traversent enfin avec ce budget nous
affirmons une nouvelle fois notre
volonté de valoriser le travail nous
voulons qu'une entreprise qui fait des
rachats d'action sujet cher au président
mat soit obligé de distribuer à ses
salariés plus de participation et plus
d'intéressement plus d' gratuite plutôt
que d'augmenter sa taxation je préfère
augmenter les rémunérations des salariés
que de remplir les caisses de l'État
nous prévoyons donc dans ce PLF 2024 que
toute entreprise qui fait du rachat
d'action sera obligé de revoir son
accord d'intéressement de revoir son
accord de participation et d'augmenter
la rémunération de ses salariés nous
voulons aussi qu'une personne qui n'a
pas d'autrre choix que de prendre son
véhicule pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail soit soutenu financièrement
c'est pour cela que nous mett en place
dans ce budget une indemnité carburant
travailleurs à hauteur de 100 € par
véhicule enfin à la suite de la
conférence sociale qui a eu lieu hier je
veux redire comme je le dis avec
constance depuis janvier 2022 que toutes
les entreprises qui le peuvent doivent
continuer à augmenter les salaires le
combat pour le travail le combat pour le
travail bien rémunéré est un combat de
tous les instants nous ne devons pas
relâcher nos
efforts mon dernier
message sera très
simple ne cédons pas aux sirènes de la
vieille politique à chaque budget depuis
7 ans j'entends revenir le même champ
séduisant des mêmes sirènes plus de
dépenses publiques plus de dettes plus
de taxes plus de dépenses dans tous les
champs d'intervention de l'État et la
France arrivera à Bonport ce champ des
sirènes comme tous les champs de toutes
les sirènes est un piège il conduira
tout droit sur les récifs du
surendettement et de
l'appauvrissement la réalité avec
laquelle nous avons affaire est bien
différente de ce que chantent ces
sirènes constamment depuis des années la
réalité c'est que nous conservons un
niveau de dépenses publique et
d'imposition parmi les plus élevé au
monde et que nous devons donc continuer
sans relâche comme le fait cette
majorité à réduire la dépenses publi
réduire le niveau de dette réduire le
niveau de fiscalité réduire le niveau
d'imposition et réduire le niveau de
taxe qui pèse sur les ménages comme sur
les entreprises la réalité ce sont des
incertitudes géopolitiques qui doivent
nous amener à reconstituer des marges de
manœuvre financière sans quoi nous
serions irresponsables aux yeux de nos
compatriotes et juger sévèrement dans
les mois et les années qui viennent la
réalité c'est qu'il y a des
investissements indispensables à faire
dès maintenant dans la transition
écologique dans la sécurité dans
l'éducation et qu'il faut bien dégager
des marges de manœuvre financière en
réduisant dépenses inutiles dans le
fonctionnement pour financer ces
investissements indispensables dans les
secteurs que je viens de mentionner la
réalité c'est que le 21e siècle
s'annonce comme difficile pour les
grandes nations occidentales qui
n'auront pas eu le courage de remettre
leur compte public en bon ordre derrière
ce budget par conséquent c'est la
puissance française qui se joue et la
puissance française ne s'achète pas à
crédit elle se construit par
l'investissement par l'innovation par la
reconstitution de nos capacités de
production elle se reconstruit par le
travail elle se reconstruit par l'effort
c'est le chemin que nous vous
proposons merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
kaznav ministre délégué chargé des
comptes
[Applaudissements]
publics madame la Présidente
monsieur le le ministre cher Bruno Le
Maire Monsieur le Président de la
Commission des des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du du budget Mesdames
et Messieurs les député je suis très
heureux de vous présenter avec Bruno Le
Maire ce projet de loi de finance pour
2024 ce projet de loi de finance il a
été construit avec un cap clair investir
pour l'avenir investir pour l'avenir
c'est d'abord maîtriser nos compte
public si l'État a pu protéger pendant
les crises c'est qu'il avait réduit son
déficit et dégager des marges de
manœuvre partant calme en 2018 je le
rappelle notre déficit était repassé
significativement sous la barre des 3 %.
après les crises successives il est de
notre responsabilité de sortir de cette
période d'exception pour nos comptes
publics nous prévoyons ainsi une
nouvelle étape de réduction du déficit
en 2024 qui s'établira à 4,4 % du PIB le
déficit budgétaire de l'État va baisser
de de 165 à 145 milliards d'euros il
aurait été plus facile de repousser à
demain ce retour à la normale nous
n'avons pas cédé à cette tentation
investir pour l'avenir c'est préserver
la croissance française dans un contexte
international bouleversé et un contexte
économique incertain nous devons
poursuivre notre politique résolue et
efficace en faveur du plein emploi la
vitalité de notre économie notre Capac
ité à créer des emplois en particulier
des emplois industriels sont la première
réponse aux préoccupations légitimes des
Français pour leur pouvoir d'achat mais
aussi pour la soutenabilité de nos
finances publiques c'est parce que nous
tenons à préserver cette dynamique
essentiel que nous n'augmentons pas les
impôts et que nous poursuivons les
baisses d'impôts de production investir
pour l'avenir c'est reconnaître que nous
avons deux dettes une dette publique et
une dette écologique à laquelle il il
faut s'attaquer le projet de loi de
finance pour 20224 consacre un
investissement inédit en faveur de la
transition écologique avec 10 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour la
rénovation énergétique des logements et
des bâtiments publics pour décarboner
nos transports pour accompagner le
nouveau modèle agricole pour créer une
industrie verte et pour transformer
notre modèle énergétique ces dépenses
vertes vont aussi permettre
d'accompagner les ménages les Français
ont besoin d'investir dans la transition
écologique
pour passer à l'électrique pour leur
voiture et pour isoler leur logement les
aider est un enjeu climatique mais aussi
économique et social sans cet
investissement supplémentaire de l'État
nous ne tiendrons pas nos objectifs
climatiques il aurait été plus facile de
repousser à demain ces investissements
en creusant notre dette écologique nous
n'avons pas céd à cette
tentation investir pour l'avenir c'est
enfin avoir des services publics plus
for notrejet de lo finance poursuit
l'investissement dans nos services
publics régaliens en cohérence avec les
lois de programmation votées ici par le
Parlement hélas l'actualité de ces
derniers jours nous rappelle combien cet
effort est indispensable nous
investissons dans l'école en finançant
les mesures nécessaires de
revalorisation du métier d'enseignant il
aurait été plus facile de repousser à
demain ce réarmement des services
publics de première ligne là encore nous
n'avons pas cédé à cette tentation le
budget que nous vous proposons est un
budget d'équilibre qui ne renonce à
aucune de nos priorités et pourtant
certains nous reprochent l'austérité les
Hauses de crédit de l'éducation
nationale de la police de la gendarmerie
de la justice de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche comme les
créations de postes qui vont permettre
de recruter plus de 8200 agents publics
supplémentaires sont une réponse à ceux
qui nous reprochent d'avoir délaissé nos
services publics il faut accélérer le
verdissement
de toutes nos dépenses publiques état
collectivité opérateurs et pour cela
nous avons besoin d'une boussole commune
cette boussole commune ce sont les
budgets verts dont je souhaite la
généralisation aux opérateurs et aux
grandes collectivités force c'est de
constater que les groupes d'opposition
ne partagent pas les grandes priorités
que nous proposons aux Français dans ce
projet de loi de finance et les grands
équilibres qui les portent mais je
constate aussi qu'il n'y a pas de projet
alternatif susceptible de sembl
davantage la première partie de ce
projet de loi de finance bien que
largement amendé n'a pas trouvé le
soutien d'une majorité d'entre vous en
commission des amendements ont certes
rassemblé des majorités mais le budget
est un équilibre d'ensemble et ne peut
se réduire à une somme d'articles et
d'amendements sur cet équilibre
d'ensemble il n'existe pas de projet
alternatif entre ceux qui veulent une
baisse drastique du déficit et des
coupes sombres dans les dépenses et ceux
qui nous accusent d'austérité il n'y a
pas de point de rencontre entre ceux qui
veulent dépenser plus sur la transition
écologique et ceux qui veulent brunir
nos dépenses et notre fiscalité il y a
une vraie incompatibilité entre ceux qui
voudraient baisser très fortement les
impôts et ceux qui veulent taxer quoi
qu'il en coûte pour l'activité
économique il y a là aussi une
divergence de fond malgré ces
divergences de fond nous bâtissons ce
texte avec le Parlement le dialogue
entre nous a été et et sera continue
après les ministres Bruno Lemer et
Thomas kazenav la parole est à er
coqurel le président de la commission
des finances le député la France
insoumise est évidemment très critique
vis-à-vis de ce budget
2024 le budget qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui ne résoudra rien il
n'atteindra pas les objectifs de
réduction de déficit que s'est donné le
gouvernement il répondra encore moins
aux besoins des Français le gouvernement
s'est en effet donné pour feuille de
route ramener le déficit à 4,4 % en 2024
pour le conduire à 2,16 en 2027 le tout
sans augmenter les impôts ce qui revient
à espérer une croissance soutenue croisé
à une baisse des dépenses publiques
historiques sauf que la croissance
espérée ne sera pas au rendez-vous vous
avez ramené vos estimations de 18 à 1,4
% mais toutes les institutions
économiques et économistes l'estime à
bien moins que cela le FCE annonce par
exemple aujourd'hui le chiffre de 0,8
quand à réaliser les économies annoncées
vous constatez vous-même que c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire on a BR de
partisan d'une politique néolibérale il
n'est pas si facile de saabrer dans les
budgets sociaux quand le pouvoir d'achat
est en berne et menace la consommation
populaire que la pauvreté s'accroit
encore que la crise du logement se
transforme en bombe sociale alors certes
et c'est déjà trop pour un état social
affaibli par des années d'austérité le
budget proposé ne su pas la hausse de
l'inflation la fin du bouclier
énergétique aggravera encore la
situation de bcoup alors que l'inflation
persiste encore dans l'énergie que des
que les économies grâce à vos réformes
qui s'en sont prises aux chômeurs et au
retraités accentueront les inégalités ce
qui d'ailleurs se révélera plus
compliqué que prévu quand tous les
partenaires sociaux refusent un rap sur
les comptes agic Arco mais vous avez
reporter à 2025 le plus gros des baisses
des dépenses publiques structurelles
cette fois sans d'ailleurs oser dire
lesqueles ont laminé ce qui a rel relevé
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
d'ailleurs vous cherchez encore
paraît-il un milliard d'économie j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure c'est en
réalité votre politique macro-économique
qui est dans la passe non seulement a
fait grimper les inégalités à un niveau
historique mais elle est incapable
d'atteindre ses propres objectifs sans
doute parce qu'au fond elle est
incapable d'affronter les crises que
nous connaissons et qui permettent
d'avancer sans trop avoir
malheureusement peur de se tromper que
les quis qu'il en coûte sont devant et
non derrière nous non seulement elle est
incapable de les affronter mais la
situation dans laquelle elle place la
société l'état nos services publics nos
mécanismes de solidarité amplifie
l'effet de ces crises plutôt qu'elle ne
les corrige au cœur du budget devrait
être la bifurcation écologique pour
atteindre l'objectif de la neutralité
carbone les économistes jean-pisan Ferri
et Selma mafous estiment nécessaire un
investissement public à hauteur de 34
milliards d'euros vous en vous en
annoncez seulement SEP en expliquant
qu'il des petits dans les collectivités
territoriales ou les organismes de
financement public autant vous dire que
je ne crois pas une telle multiplication
des pains quand la mise de départ de
l'État est si faible et que dans le même
temps on invite les dites collectivités
à baisser leurs dépenses publiques je
note également que dans les pistes de
financement de son plan l'économiste
pisaniféie propose de recourir à une
taxe sur les plus riches et à laisser
filer un peu plus la dette on y
reviendra demain sans doute dans le
débat sur la dette mais l'urgence
écologique ne peut faire oublier
d'autres urgences la première c'est le
pouvoir d'achat il recule pour une
grande partie de la population à
commencer par les plus défavorisés les
salaires n'ont effectivement pas suivi
l'inflation selon une récente étude de
Rex code la perte de pouvoir d'achat des
salariés du secteur privé est estimé à
2,5 % entre 2019 et 2023 et encore cela
cage des disparités pour le secteur
public la situation est encore plus
grave après un gel du point d'indice de
plus de 5 ans de valorisation sont
intervenu mais à des niveaux bien
inférieurs à l'augmentation des prix
plus forte sur l'énergie et les produits
alimentaires l'inflation a pesé durement
sur les dépenses de première nécessité
elle a exposé les ménages les plus
démunis à cet arbitrage impossible entre
ce loger ou se nourrir selon l'INC 47 %
des ménages déclarent ainsi avoir changé
leurs habitudes de consommation
alimentaire et lors de l'audition des
associations de solidarité en commission
des finances toutes ont évoqué une une
aggravation préoccupante de la situation
il est donc d'urgent d'agir davantage en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat la seconde
urgence non pas en terme hiérarchique
c'est la crise du logement c'est une
bombe sociale en train d'exploser alors
que seuls les plus précaires ne trouvez
pas ce leuger décemment ce constat
s'étant désormais aux classes moyenne
c'est au moins des constats que nous
pourrions partager sauf que vous
remettez globalement cette question à
une future loi logement il n'est pas
possible d'attendre il faut des mesures
immédiates dont l'objectif sera de faire
baisser les prix et permettre à tous
d'accéder à un logement digne
troisièmement nos services publics sont
dans une situation préoccupante à force
de diminution des moyens qui leur sont
accordés les hôpitaux souffrent toujours
et les services d'urgence d'urgence sont
en détresse la dernière rentrée scolaire
a été une des pires de ces dernières
années en étant marqué par des
suppressions de postes d'enseignant et
des fermetures de classe cette
dégradation est des services publics est
aussi la source d'un renforcement des
inégalités sociales si durable à vivre
dans les quartiers populaires urbanisés
mais aussi dans les zones rurales et
périurbaines autant de territoires qui
ont pour point commun l'impression
justifié souvent que notre République
les abandonne ainsi progressivement le
paradoxe de ce budget c'est que vous
avez été obligé de reconnaître en paro
monsieur le ministre un certain nombre
de ces évidences mais sans la plupart du
temps en tenir compte dans vos
propositions ou dans le soutien à des
amendements qui ont été proposés y
compris venant de votre majorité oui je
trouve positif car c'est au fond
reconnaître que nous avions raison Bruno
Le Maire de proposer une taxe sur les
les profits des concessionnaires
autoroutiers car je préfère cela à une
période où vous expliquez qu'il n'y
avait pas de super profit mais des
profits tout courts oui je trouve cela
positif que devant l'imposition globale
ridicule des milliardaires en France
révélé par l'étude IPP Bercy qui cumulé
revenus professionnel et revenus
personnel ne dépasse pas 25 % de taux
d'imposition vous me donnez raison à
légitimement un impôt minimal mais et en
le renvoyant un accord européen
c'est-à-dire à la singlinglin vu les
règles d'unanimité alors que c'est
maintenant que nous avons besoin de
recettes supplémentaire et que pour
faire changer l'Europe rien ne voit
après tout que des pays forts comme la
France fort de leur puissance économique
ouvr la voie c'est pourquoi je suis
heureux de ce qui s'est passé en
commission je suis d'abord heureux que
nous soyons parvenus à examiner les 2400
amendement et ce dans un esprit d'écoute
et d'échange d'arguments qui fait
honneur à notre à notre commiss et j'en
remercie à ce propos l'ensemble des
commissaires des administrateurs et des
collaborateurs
oui je suis heureux pas seulement parce
que le budget n'a pas été adopté mais
aussi parce que finalement c'est dessiné
comme je le pensais la possibilité d'une
majorité en faveur d'une plus grande
justice fiscale mais aussi qui a entendu
vos appels Bruno Le Maire en vous
proposant plus de recettes sur 105
amendements différents qui ont été
adoptés 38 l'uront été contre l'avis du
rapporteur dont 15 qui constituent des
recette supplémenta pour l'État à
hauteur de plus de 15 milliards 15 fois
ce que vous demandez Bruno Le Maire je
ne vais pas citer tous ces amendements
mais beaucoup viennent de votre majorité
moi ce que je vous propose messieurs les
ministres c'est d'accepter la voix
majoritaire qui monte de l'assemblée de
reconnaître la nécessité d'une
démocratie parlementaire vous allez
adopter le 493 mais il y a deux manières
de l'adopter so l' en annulant tous ces
amendements soit vous l'adoptez en
acceptant que des compromis qui viennent
de la majorité de l'Assemblée c'est un
choix que vous aurez à
faire après l'échec de la motion de
rejet défendu par la France insoumise
chaque groupe défend sa position sur ce
budget les députés savent que c'est l'un
des rares moments où ils pourront faire
valoir leurs arguments la discussion va
être écourtée car le gouvernement n'a
pas de majorité pour voter sa loi de
finance alors l'ombre du 493 plane dès
cette première
séance la première
raison de notre opposition c'est que
vous ne tenez pas les dépenses des
dépenses continuent d'augmenter le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques prévoit
une hausse de dépenses primaires nettes
de 2,6 % et non pas du tout une baisse
comme vous l'annoncez parmi les 580
milliards d'euros de dépenses de l'État
les dépenses d'investissement mes chers
collègues ne représente plus que 29
milliards en 2024 soit seulement 6 % du
budget général dont la moitié au titre
de la défense une fois de plus les
Françaises et les Français vont donc
s'endetter uniquement pour gérer les
affaires courantes la deuxième raison se
trouve du côté des recettes d'une part
les hypothèses macro-économiques sur
lesquels vous fondez vos prévisions sont
optimistes de la veu même de Haut
Conseil des finances publiques vous
prévoyez une croissance en volume de 14
c'était 1 avant ce n'est pas raisonnable
vous auriez dû vous fonder sur des
estimations plus modestes à 0,8 ou 1 %
comme la majorité des analystes de même
m manière vos hypothèses d'inflation
sont très favorables et ne tiennent pas
compte de la hausse récente des prix du
pétrole troisièmement vous tentez de
maquiller le sold de public par tous les
moyens en 2024 le gouvernement prévoit
un déficit de l'État de 145 milliards
d'euros certes il s'agit d'une
amélioration puisque ce déficit diminit
de 20 milliards par rapport à 2023 mais
le sol structurel lui ne s'améliore que
de 0,4 points de PIB soit de 10
milliards ce qui est plus grave c'est
que près de 14 milliards sur les 16
milliards d'économies que vous annoncez
sont des économies de constatation lié à
l'extinction de dispositifs temporaires
vous ne vous livrez pas un réel effort
structurel de maîtrise de la dépense
face à un gouvernement qui veut baisser
les impôts alors qu'il n'en a pas les
moyens qui ne propose aucune économie
structurelle significative et qui prévè
saisir l'argent des administrations de
sécurité sociale plutôt que de
rationaliser son propre budget le group
groupe Viot votera en l'état de ce texte
contre le projet de loi de finance
50 ans 50 longues années un demi-siècle
que les gouvernements qui se sont
succédés présentent systématiquement
sans aucune exception un budget en
déficit je vous l'ai dit en commission
je vous le redis ici 50 ans normalement
quand on se marie et qu'on s'aime c'est
les nos d'or avec vous pas d'amour même
platonique ce sont bien les no de plomb
50 ans que vous plombez notre pays par
plus de déficit plus de dettes toujours
plus d'impôts et pourtant moins de
service publics efficace votre héritage
au bout de tant d'années c'est
l'exaspération fiscale de nos
concitoyens face aux injustices ce sont
des familles et des retraités qui ne
peuvent vivre de leur travail des
classes moyennes prises entre l'enclume
de la cistana et le marteau des
privilèges oui vous les macronistes et
avant les fausses alternances de gauche
et de droite tous vous n'avez jamais été
capable d' équilibrer les comptes
publics malgré un niveau de fiscalité et
de prélèvement obligatoire en perpétuel
alourdissement quel triste anniversaire
pour la France que ce nouveau cadeau
empoisonné que vous lui offrez en
échange de la confiance que nos
concitoyens vous avez pourtant accordé
pour ces 50 ans de déficit messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre pardon
vous n'avez pas fait les choses à moitié
vous faites un nouveau cadeau à la
France de 285 milliards d'euros
d'endettement 285 milliards d'euros
voici le montant vertigineux que le
gouvernement va emprunter en 2024 pour
financer le déficit public et le
refinancement de la dette un niveau
record record d'impôt en valeur absolue
en valeur relative qui cette année
encore vont s'alourdir de 17 milliards
d'euros en particulier les impôts les
plus injuste la TVA la hausse des impôts
est deux fois supérieure à l'inflation
elle est quatre fois supérieure à la
hausse de la croissance attendu
autrement dit le raquette des classes
moyennes et des PME continu de toute
évidence Monsieur le Maire invente des
résultats économiques imaginaires et
vous monsieur CASNAV vous entendez des
voix des voix des oppositions qui
seraient d'accord avec vos propositions
les voix de Jean sauver la France les
voix de Thomas les conduiront à la ruine
je vous le dis il n'y a aucun rapport
entre ce que les prop entre ce que les
oppositions pardon ont demandé au
dialogue de Bery et les propositions
macronistes que vous voulez imposer sous
un consensus imaginaire j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses de la part des
ministres c'est un projet sérieux
qu'on est à l'euro
prè c'est de mots que vous avez à la
bouche le sérieux
budgétaire votre projet de loi de
finance il est pas sérieux les
prévisions de croissance vous avez pas
arrêté de les modifier au début on était
à 18 maintenant on est à 14 alors que
l'OFCE la Banque de France nous disent
que les prévisions de croissance elles
sont pas bonnes elles sont à 08 % 0,9 %
une paille quoi juste quelques dizaines
de milliards d'euros
sur les prévisions
d'inflation ça fait des années que le
ministre Bruno Lemer court après le pic
de l'inflation il gravit il gravit ça ne
s'arrête jamais ça fait 2 ans qu'on est
censé être dans le pic de l'inflation
mais Monsieur Bruno Le Maire a
visiblement perdu son oxygène à force de
gravir ce
pic ce que vous auriez pu faire par
contre au lieu de vous gargariser
d'avoir rien fait vous auriez pu ne
serait-ce que pour les grandes bois pour
les grands groupes revenir sur un taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés à 33 % comme ça
l'était avant le casakena Macron là je
vous assure que vous auriez eu des
rentrées fiscales conséquentes pour
réarmer nos services publics c'est pas
le choix que vous avez fait il y a
quelque chose qui a éclaté aux yeux de
tout le monde en commission vous êtes
minoritaire vous êtes minoritaire jusque
dans votre
majorité vous êtes incapable même
d'écouter vos propres alliés parce que
vous allez faire un 49S on sait que vous
allez pas les
reprendre
l'augmentation de la taxe sur les
transactions financières on aurait pu la
faire si vous cherchez de l'argent pour
par exemple pour financer vos
exonérations de cotisation on l'a voté
ça aurait pu rapporter 11 milliards
d'euros à l'État sur les transactions
financières mais qui peut être compte ça
dans la période actuelle budget après
budget nous alertons le gouvernement sur
la situation financière de notre pays et
ses conséquences sur les Français
explosion de la dette 45000 € par
français et de ses intérêts la France
championne européenne des taxes et
impôts une des dépenses publi qui
augmente alors que nos concitoyens
voient chaque jour le service public qui
leur est réellement utile se dégrader je
pense évidemment à la santé au soutien
aux personnes âgées dépendantes à
l'école à la sécurité voilà votre bilan
malheureusement en matière budgétaire
mais quelles conséquences concrètes
aujourd'hui pour les Français notamment
pour ceux qui travaillent dur qui se
lèvent tous les matins qui contribuent
largement à la solidarité nationale et
n'ont jamais droit à rien je veux parler
des classes moyennes
aujourd'hui concrètement les Français
font face à une explosion du coût du
logement une explosion des prix des
carburants une perte de pouvoir d'achat
pour les familles il n'arrivent plus à
faire face or rien dans ce budget ne
répond à cette crise rien sur l'accès au
logement tout d'abord il s'agit du
premier poste de dépenses des ménages
nous faisons face aujourd'hui à une
hausse massive des taux d'intérêt une
hausse des loyers une chute de la
construction et un logement social
totalement débordé
c'est une grave crise sociale qui se
profile madame la députée je perds de
l'argent chaque fois que je vais
travailler voilà ce que me disent mes
concitoyens qui n'ont d'autre choix que
de se déplacer en voiture et ce n'est
pas un chèque dérisoire de 100 € ciblé
sur une fraction de Français qui
résoudra le problème le prix du
carburant est constitué de plus de
moitié de taxes sur 2 € le litre de
Gasol plus d'un € est récolté par les
caisses de l'État les cas encaissent
donc 40 milliards d'euros de taxes sur
les carb carburant avec les républicains
nous demandons qu'une partie de cet
argent soit rendu aux Français
aujourd'hui avec une baisse immédiate de
la titicpe permettant une économie de
12,5 centimes d'euros par litre pour
tous pour un coût de 5 milliards
monsieur le ministre je ne doute pas
malheureusement qu'il y aura un 493 mais
je souhaite impérativement que vous
continuez la défiscalisation sur les
pourboir je n'ai pas pu en parler en
commission et il est impératif que cet
élément soit dans le texte final pour le
pouvoir d'achat de tous les travailleurs
de la
restauratie le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 n'est pas un budget de rigueur
ce'est pas un budget d'austérité mais
c'est un budget de responsabilité et
d'ambition vis-à-vis de nos finan
publique vis-à-vis des Français et vis
vous allez voir et vis-à-vis de la
transition écologique car oui le projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 est un
budget de
responsabilité tout d'abord de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de nos finances
publiques il consacre en effet 16
milliards d'euros d'économie budgétaire
soit 6 milliards de plus que ce qui ce
qui était initialement prévu car oui
notre objectif est clair et assumé c'est
celui de réduire notre déficit public à
2,7 % du produit intérieur brut d'ici
2027 conformément à la trajectoire
pluréannuelle de redressement de nos
finances publiques c'est une question de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Françaises
et des Français et de crédibilité
vis-à-vis de ceux qui nous financent
tous les jours pour financer notre
modèle social grâce à l'adoption de ce
projet de loi de finance nous l'espérons
nous parviendrons à tenir notre objectif
de déficit de 4,4 % de déficit public en
2024 mes chers collègues depuis 3 ans
nous avons su faire face à une
succession de crise de crise majeure en
pleine tempête qu' s'agisse du covid de
l'impact de la guerre en Ukraine ou de
la crise inflationniste l'économie
française a démontré sa solidité et si
nous avons ex c'est parce que l'État et
la puissance publique dans son ensemble
a mis en œuvre tous les moyens
nécessaires pour protéger les Français
quoi qu'il en coûte mais l'heure est
désormais au rétablissement de nos
comptes publics quoi qu'il arrive parce
que cet objectif c'est celui que ce
projet de loi de finance porte oui ce P
ce projet de loi de finance est un
budget de
responsabilité de responsabilité
vis-à-vis des Français ensuite parce que
c'est ce budget renforce
considérablement les moyens de la
justice les moyens de la défense les
moyens de la sécurité de l'éducation
nationale du pouvoir d'achat et cela
répond ainsi aux attentes et aux
préoccupations légitimes de nos
compatriotes quel qu'ils soi ou où
qu'ils se trouent et quel que soient
leurs opinions politique ce budget porte
par ailleurs une très forte ambition en
faveur de la transition écologique le
plus vert jamais présenté jusqu'à alors
il comporte 39,7 milliards d'euros de
dépenses favorables à l'environnement
soit 7 % des des dépenses qui agiront
directement sur la protection de
l'environnement et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique il concréti le
plan épargne avenir climat il instaure
le crédit d'impôt industrie verte et il
coupe dans les dépenses fiscales brunes
tout en accompagnant les secteurs
concernés au premier des rangs au
premier rang desquels nos agriculteurs
ce budget est aussi celui de la lutte
contre les fraudes il datte les
administrations des moyens de lutter
contre ces comportements inacceptables
qui minent un peu plus jour après jour
le contrô social qui nous lit voici donc
ce qu'est le budget 2024 un budget
post-crise qui permet de regarder vers
l'avenir et qui malgré le périmètre
contraint qui est le nôtre porte des
ambition dont nous pouvons être fier
tout en respectant l'exercice imposé
d'un retour progressif de déficit en
dessous des 3 % en 2027 dans ce cadre
ainsi fixé les priorités du groupe
démocrate sont claires adresser de
premières réponses efficaces à la crise
du logement à laquelle notre pays fait
face ainsi que proposer des mesures en
faveur d'une plus grande justice fiscale
nous souhaitons enrichir ce texte en ce
sens enfin en synthèse si je devais
qualifier ce budget en trois mots je
dirais que ce budget est un budget
d'action de durabilité et d'équilibre
dans ce contexte et avec la
responsabilité qui nous caractérise le
groupe démocrate votera pour la première
partie de ce projet de loi de finance 20
je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie le groupe socialiste est tot
des accord avec les hypothèses sur
lesquelles vous avez élaboré ce budget
nous les jugeons beaucoup trop
optimistes et monsieur le ministre je le
dis sincèrement j'espère me tromper ce
budget il est non seulement irréaliste
mais il est également vous me
pardonnerez l'expression à côté de la
plaque il fait fausse route parce qu'il
ne permet pas de répondre aux priorités
et aux urgences des Françaises et des
Français et pour illustrer mon propos
j'aborderai successivement quatre
urgences d'abord le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation continue d'amputer
cruellement le pouvoir d'achat de nombre
de Français alors oui certains s'en
sortent très bien mais beaucoup de nos
compatriotes qui pourtant travaillent ou
bénéficient d'une pension de retraite
bien méritée n'arrivent plus à vivre
digement 30 jours par mois j'en viens à
une autre priorité la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et la
protection de la
biodiversité le diagnostic posé par la
première ministre en join est parfait
mais il nous faut là aussi constater
que les mesures contenues dans ce budget
ne sont pas à la hauteur des enjeux et
aux engagements pris par le Président de
la République autre crise le
logement depuis 2017 monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez cessé de faire des
économies sur le dos du logement les
résultats de cette politique sont
catastrophiques et pourtant vous
continuez à faire la sour d'oreille le
logement c'est le premier poste de
dépenses des ménages et il sont de plus
en plus nombreux à peiner face à un coût
qui ne cesse d'augmenter dernier sujet
qui figure également très haut sur
l'échelle des priorités de nos
concitoyens peut-être à la première
place la santé sur ce sujet on pourrait
dire la situation s'est dégradée mais on
ne pouvait pas prévoir c'est faux les
déserts médicaux avancent au même rythme
que la République recule sur nos
territoires vous l'aurez compris nous ne
voterons pas votre budget monsieur le
ministre synonyme pour beaucoup de
français appartenant aux classes
populair aux classes moyennes d'ffs
surdimensionné alors qu'en même vous
poursuivez une politique favorable non
pas aux riches mais aux ultra riches
c'est-à-dire à une toute toute toute
petite poignée de contribuable depuis
presque 2 ans maintenant nous vivons
dans un contexte d'inflation qui a
bousculé nos habitudes ce niveau
d'inflation a été particulièrement
maîtrisé par les décisions que vous avez
porté monsieur le ministre pour en
limiter les impacts mais pour un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens l'impact sur
la vie quotidienne est bien plus
important que que pour d'autres notre
groupe horizon et apparenté soutient
donc une revalorisation uniforme pour
tous les Français les pensions de bases
des retraité seront revalorisé de 5,2 %
compte tenu de la règle d'automaticité
fixée appliquons donc ce même taux de
revalorisation pour les tranches
d'impôts sur le revenu la justice
fiscale et sociale c'est aussi
l'imposition de tous et je veux saluer
monsieur le ministre votre combat
remporté sur l'imposition minimale des
grandes entreprises international c'est
une réelle avancée qui nous permet
d'ouvrir les prochaines étapes avec la
question de l'imposition minimum des
personnes physique et nous porterons un
amendement d'appel sur ce sujet majeur
dans ce souci de justice fiscale nous
porterons également la prolongation de
la contribution sur la rente des
producteurs d'électricité pour l'année
2024 avec des paramètres renouvelés pour
ne pas mettre en difficulté certains des
acteurs
concernés la justice fiscale c'est aussi
ne pas exclure ceux qui ont besoin de
dispositifs de soutien le préatoau zéro
est un formidable outil de soutien au
ménages pour l'acquisition de leur
habitation nous portons donc avec
conviction la nécessité d'élargir les
critères de ressources de plafond et
d'éligibilité territoriale d'accès au
préateau zéro plutôt que de répondre au
défis de demain il faut plutôt relever
les défis dès
aujourd'hui car faire face à nos
engagements de réduction des gaz des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
l'horizon 2030 et réussir la transition
écologique dans le délai imparti pour
cela des moyens supplémentaires doivent
être mobilisés et ils sont conséquents
le rapport mafous et pisaniférie les
estime à 34 milliards d'euros pour
2024 le projet de loi de finance pour
2024 présente 491 milliards d'euros de
dépenses 9 milliards de moins qu'en 2023
et 349 milliards d'EUR de recette c'est
donc un déficit de 142 milliards d'euros
déficit que l'on pourrait réduire si le
volet recette de ce budget intégré
toutes on peut rêver ou des propositions
raisonnables de recettes qui sont faites
ça et là y compris dans les proches de
la
majorité je pense à l'impôt exceptionnel
sur le patrimoine financier bien sûr des
plus aisés proposé par Selma mafou et
pisaniferie qui pourrait rapporter 5
milliards d'euros dès l'année 2020 24 je
pense aux propositions de nos collègues
Matth et sensu dans le rapport de la
fiscalité du patrimoine et plus
précisément aux mesure visant à
accroître la contribution des revenus du
capital au redressement des finances
publiques le groupe écologiste
maintiendra les positions exprimé en
commission des finances pour relever les
défis d'aujourd'hui sans attendre ceux
de demain je vous remercie je vous
remercie
hier s'est ouverte la conférence sociale
sur les salaires à cette occasion vous
avez affirmer monsieur le ministre je
cite que vous étiez contre l'indexation
des salaires sur l'inflation contre la
hausse généralisée des salaires et
opposé à un coup de pouce du smille
c'est donc une conférence sur les bas
salaires non pour les augmenter mais
pour qu'il reste bas
êtes-vous à ce point déconnecté monsieur
le ministre du portefeuille des Français
à la lecture de ce projet de loi de
finances tout porte à le croire rien ou
si peu pour les français concernant leur
pouvoir de vivre rien sur le prix des
denrées alimentaires rien sur le prix de
l'essence rien sur le prix de l'énergie
depuis 2017 vous êtes sourd à la
situation sociale du pays depuis 2017
votre seule boussole a été la politique
de l'offre la théorie du ruissellement
des riches vers les couches moyennes et
modestes qui est à l'œuvre selon la
Dache quand les gros maigrissent les
maigres meurent mais c'est une hérésie
toutes les études montrent que
l'accroissement des patrimoines des
ultrares
1170 milliards d'euros en 2022 pour les
500 plus grandes fortunes s'accompagne
d'un taux de pauvre
qui progresse le budget 2024 répond à
des choix et non à des besoins le budget
2024 ne répondra pas à ces enjeux forceé
de constater qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
en accord avec la teneur du texte
proposé la discussion en commission
ainsi que le vote sanction par lequel
elle s'est terminé l'ont démontré nous
connaissons donc l'issue de cette
séquence un 493 qui viendra une
nouvellefis empêcher notre assemblée de
se faire de faire évoluer ce texte et de
se
prononcer dès le lendemain de cette
discussion générale ellisabeth borne
monte à la tribune et déclenche le 493
sur le volet recette c'est le premier
d'une longue série sur les différentes
parties du budget la loi de finance sera
définitivement adopté quelques jours
avant Noël avec un dernier
493 dans la version finale le
gouvernement a gardé quelques centaines
d'amendements venus des députés des
amendements de tous les groupes
politiques sauf du rassemblement
national et de la France insoumise c'est
la fin de ces grands débats à bientôt
sur
LCP